[Music]
instead of talking about the news I'm
going to talk about Christmas because
it's the most exciting time of the year
now sure we have to celebrate while
surrounded by a million stressful news
stories the world is falling apart
around us but we're going to enjoy the
holidays anyway and if not
we're going to pretend to
[Music]
it's that special time of year again in
so many ways we're blessed we're gonna
gather for the holidays and I'm gonna
I'm gonna do my best
I've got my present I've got my mess
I gotta beat That Makes Me Wanna Shake
my ass
I'm gonna wow them bet your last start
so come on let's hang out this Christmas
and pretend to have a good time
the whole world is crumbling I feel numb
whenever I watch the news the state of
the world has given this girl a bad case
of the blues
if Verizon hates crimes is on your mind
me too so let's sing out this Christmas
and pretend to have a good time
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
y'all ask me over
and I'll say yes
[Applause]
but just so you know I'm gonna be a mess
starting to lose my faith in mankind say
come on let's hang out this Christmas
and pretend to have a good time hey
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ah student debts nuclear threats that
shit's making my armpits wet you won't
sense my feeling of impending doom
wherever that beat goes boom boom boom
[Music]
till you make it let's pretend to have a
good time
yeah
that's how I feel
are you starting to get into the
Christmas spirit
we'll catch up [ __ ] I've been in this
[ __ ] since September
[Applause]
this is my absolute favorite time of
year it honestly is and there are so
many amazing Christmas traditions like
making stockings
making Christmas cookies re-gifting but
gonna die
foreign
[Applause]
die on camera
[Laughter]
making a Christmas wish look I know it
sounds silly but I like to believe
Christmas wishes are real but a lot of
people say Christmas wishes aren't real
who says they're not
[Applause]
wow
[Applause]
Facts of Life Kim Fields yes that's
right the Kim Fields that rocked wig
after glorious wig on Living Single
click show the upshaws dropping February
16th
that's me oh my God it's an honor
McKay Mrs Fields That's The Cookie Lady
well what are you doing here are you an
audience member girl no
Angel and I am here to grant you your
Christmas wish your Christmas
hmm yes I am it's one of my side hustles
now I can grant you one Christmas wish
tonight Amber so think very carefully
and when you're ready let me know what
it is look I don't have to think at all
I know exactly what I want okay World
Peace
you want peace all over the world like
for everybody
like you don't even want a little bit of
drama oh that's a good point I do love a
good drag okay then I'm I wish there
were enough black therapists in the
world for everybody
[Applause]
now
[Applause]
I I could do that but then some black
therapists would end up with white
clients which means that one of them is
going to end up listening to a white
woman complaining about the price of
kale
oh no man we can't have that okay how
about this I wish I could talk to
animals
no you do not want to have a
conversation with a dog the only thing
they want to talk about butts uh okay oh
I wish that Shonda Rhimes would write
all my emails okay okay now see I like
how you thinking but see if I granted
that wish all your emails would be an
hour long have dramatic monologues in
the middle and somehow there'll be a
sappy song playing in the background oh
no we can't have that no no no no no
although I do have to say those emails
would be riveting
oh I got it I want women all over the
world to have the right to do whatever
they want with their bodies
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah I grant wishes I ain't a miracle
worker
what should I wish for
um ah here we go Amber how about a
lipstick that doesn't come off when you
eat pudding
okay now that's a good wish all right
honey well consider it granted
[Music]
whoa thanks Kim Fields
you're welcome Amber rant and what's her
name Amber Ruffin
[Applause]
that's the thing about the Christmas
season you never know when something
magical will happen
oh listen you know what that means
whenever a bell rings an angel gets its
wings
[Music]
yes
yes
merry Christmas everybody I love you
Amber
I can't believe I got to make a
Christmas wish it was so exciting no
I get to cross that off my Christmas
to-do list
oh that's uh that's really so that's
really awesome that's so smart you know
you have a Christmas to-do list what
else is on it uh just normal stuff
decorating the tree um drinking eggnog
bumping butts underneath the mistletoe
[Laughter]
wait what'd you just say drinking nog no
after that oh bumping butts underneath
the mistletoe
yeah you know that's not an actual
Christmas tradition right what do you
mean of course it is you hang up a
mistletoe and then when two people find
themselves underneath it they bump their
butts together
what else would you do under a mistletoe
kiss yeah gross that's not how a
mistletoe Works tarek mistletoes are for
butt bumping no no no no no no no no it
is not here I'll prove it to you hey
Wally uh yeah Turk can you please
explain to Amber the true Christmas
tradition of the mistletoe well of
course you see Amber every holiday
season folks hang up a mistletoe
Whenever two people find themselves
standing underneath it one has to hop on
the other's back and ride them like a
cowboy as they say Giddy Up horsey giddy
up
Wally what in the world that is not how
the mistletoe works of course it is here
I'll prove it to you hey Jenny uh yes
Wally you please explain to these two
the true Christmas tradition of the
mistletoe of course Wally you see guys
when you and someone else are underneath
the mistletoe you're supposed to kiss
them thank you Jenny on the forehead
what yeah and then you say in like a
teensy-weety baby voice mommy loves you
yes she does mommy loves you say what
yeah and then you give them a bottle why
I think it symbolizes the baby Jesus
isn't that right here no way whenever
you and someone else are underneath the
mistletoe you're supposed to hold still
for a very long time as they sketch a
pencil drawn portrait of you like this
one
isn't that right Natalie no you're all
wrong when you find yourself under the
mistletoe you pass a bowl around and
everyone puts cash in it then you keep
the cash
uh yeah be sure to pass that back by way
when y'all done thank you
okay okay so there's only one way to
settle this let's ask Mother Siri hey
Siri what is the tradition of mistletoe
when two people meet under the mistletoe
it's tradition for them to kiss then
they ride each other like Cowboys feed
each other the bottle draw each other
and pass a bowl around and fill it with
cash
then they bump butts
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so much lotion Derek
you believe that there are only nine
days left until Christmas I can't I'm
still trying to find gifts for everyone
on my list I'm on your list right oh
yeah definitely
well I already did my shopping and I
decorated my tree and I hung my stocking
so the next thing on my Christmas to-do
list is to write a very important letter
[Music]
Christmas Time Is Here Again I've got my
paper and I've got my pen
I'm riding Santa with my special wish
but there's only one thing on my
Christmas list
bring me a true love
a beautiful new love don't need no
presents under my tree all I want is
someone who truly loves me
bring me a true love
a beautiful new love sprinkle your magic
into my life bring me a true love on
this late at night oh
my God oh my God
Merry Christmas Amber
Merry Christmas Amber's backup singers
Merry Christmas Santa did you get my
letter I sure did did you read it of
course yay so you're gonna bring me my
true love for Christmas no
what no but I wrote it in the letter I
saw that
and it said you want me to bring you
true love yeah so a man presumably yeah
yeah so you want me to leave a human man
at your house for Christmas
well I didn't say that you did say that
yeah I heard that too
what do you think I do exactly
you're a Santa Claus and you make
people's dreams come true yeah if their
dream is to get a PlayStation 5 not a
human person
I'm a tinkerer not a trafficker
how would that even work
did you want me to build a man from
scratching my shop in the North Pole no
oh so so you were thinking baby I just
scoop up a Drifter on the way over and
you guys would hit it off not exactly
well those are pretty much the only two
ways that could work out I mean he's
making some good points yeah when you
break it down like that asking Santa for
a true love is creepy right
every year I get these insane requests
from pop singers saying Oh Santa all I
want for Christmas is for you to fix the
disaster that is my love life like what
I can't do that what do I look like
[ __ ]
how am I supposed to find a long lasting
relationship have you tried looking into
the mirror maybe the problem isn't the
men you're meeting maybe the problem is
you
better when you were only saying ooh and
ah
your backup singers are right Amber I
can't get you true love that's something
you'll find on your own if you're
willing to do some growth and
introspection hey yuck
is there anything else you want for
Christmas how about a PlayStation 5.
no way you needed to write that letter
back in June
how about a wooden fire truck fine
perfect a wooden fire truck it is have a
Merry Christmas everyone ho ho ho ho
so I don't know
you guys what do you think should we
finish this song yes and also you should
do some work on yourself
[Music]
a beautiful new love
[Music]
all right